propria first I will discuss how I reach
my decision and then I will answer any
questions you have on the topic for some
time prior to July 17 2014 neighborhood
residents purposely avoided the area in
indirectly around
Hopkinsville whose cigarettes made
cheaper by the fact that New York state
taxes had not been paid on them a liquor
store nearby sold alcohol to people who
would drink that alcohol in the park
people who would sometimes use drugs
urinate and pass out on benches there
that summer the week before there had
been reports of theft and two robberies
in the park
there were 911 planes from residents and
merchants on an ongoing basis in some
cases warnings of summonses were issued
in other cases arrests were made and
that was the situation at Tompkinsville
Park on the day officer Pantaleo
was sent with another officer to conduct
an enforcement operation when the second
officer observed mr. garner hand out
cigarettes in exchange for money they
approached mr. garner to make an arrest
that offense could have resulted in a
summons but mr. garner refused to
provide identification which meant would
have been brought to the precinct for
processing for several minutes on that
widely viewed video mr. garner makes it
abundantly clear that he will not go
willingly with the police officers he
refused to cooperate with the arrest and
to comply with lawful orders the video
also makes clear that offers officer
Pantaleo as original efforts to take mr.
Garner into custody for appropriate and
then he initially attempted to maneuver
sanctioned by the police department
officer Pantaleo first grabbed mr.
Garner's right wrist and attempted an
arm bar technique in preparation for
handcuffs to be used
mr. garner immediately twisted and
pulled and raised both of his hands
while repeatedly telling the officers to
not touch him officer Pantaleo then
wrapped his arms around mr. Garner's
upper body up to that point in his tense
and rapidly evolving situation there was
nothing to suggest that officer Pantaleo
attempted to place mr. Garner and a
chokehold but what happened next is the
matter we must address the two men
stumbled backwards towards the large
plate glass window the storefront behind
them and officer Pantaleo SPAC made
contact with the glass causing the
window to visibly buckle and raw and
warm the person videotaping the episode
later testify at the NYPD trial that he
thought bulk man would crashed through
the glass this at that point in the
video that officer Pantaleo scene with
his hands clasped together and his left
warm pressed against mr. Garner's neck
and what constitutes a chokehold
NYPD Court ruled that while certainly
not preferable that hold was acceptable
during that brief moment in time because
the risk of falling through the window
was so high but that egg's Indians
circumstance no longer existed the court
found when officer Pantaleo and mr.
garner moved to the ground as mr. garnet
balanced himself on the sidewalk on his
hands and knees Deputy Commissioner of
trials Rosemarie Maldonado found that
officer Pantaleo consciously disregarded
the substantial an unjustifiable risk of
maneuver explicitly prohibited by the
department she found that during their
struggle officer Pantaleo had the
opportunity to readjust his grip from a
prohibited child called to a less lethal
alternative but did not make use of that
opportunity instead even once mr. Garner
was moved to his side on the ground with
his left arm behind his back in his
right hand still open and extended
officer Pantaleo kept his hands clasped
and maintained the chokehold
mr. Garner's obvious distressed is
confirmed when he coughs and grimaces
moreover trials commissioner Maldonado
found that officer Pantaleo conduct
cause physical injury that meets the
penal law threshold and that his
reckless
cause multi-layered internal bruising
and hemorrhaging that impaired mr.
Garner's physical condition and caused
substantial pain and was a significant
factor in triggering an asthma attack
for all of these reasons taken together
even after reviewing officer Pantaleo s
commendable service record of nearly 300
arrests and fourteen Department medals
earned leading up to that day trial
Commissioner Maldonado recommended that
he be dismissed from the department in
making this penalty recommendation she
wrote this Tribunal recognizes that from
the outside outset mr. garner was
non-compliant compliant and
argumentative and further notes that the
patrol guide allows officers to use
reasonable force when necessary to take
an uncooperative individual into custody
what the patrol guide did not allow
however even when this individual was
resisting arrest was the use of a
prohibited chokehold as you know a
number of external authorities have
asked many of the same questions we have
about this incident on August 19 2014
about a month after mr. Garner's death
the Staten Island District Attorney's
Office announced it would impanel a
grand jury to present evidence on that
matter on December 3rd 2014 those 23
Staten Island residents voted to not
indict officer Pantaleo clearing him of
criminal wrongdoing that same day the
United States Attorney General announced
that the US Department of Justice would
conduct its own investigation into mr.
Garner's death and wave bringing federal
civil rights charges against officer
Pantaleo in the intervening years the
Justice Department made ongoing a
request to the NYPD asking us to delay
our internal disciplinary process until
its civil rights investigation was
complete we honored those requests as
their process stretched from one
administration to the next with no
action by federal prosecutors and so on
July 21st 2018 we decided to begin NYPD
proceedings members of the public in
general and miss mr. Garner's family in
particular have grown understandably
impatient the trial began on May 13 2019
on July 16th 2019 one day before the
five-year statute of limitations expired
the Justice Department announced it
would not file federal charges against
officer Pantaleo then on August 2nd 2019
with officer Pantaleo is NYPD trial
concluded trials Commissioner mountain
on are ruled that officer Pantaleo s use
of a prohibited chokehold was reckless
and constituted a gross deviation from
the standard of conduct established for
a New York City police officer after
noting that officer Pantaleo had
admitted he was aware that child calls
are prohibited by the department she
further concluded which strongly worded
and repeated warnings about the
potentially lethal effects of choke
holds found throughout multiple sections
of the training materials it is evident
that the department made its 2006
recruits keenly aware of the inherent
dangers associated with the application
of pressure to the neck given this
training a New York City police officer
could reasonably be expected to be aware
of the potentially lethal effects
connected with the use of a prohibited
show called to be vigilant in issuing
its use from the start of this process I
was determined to carry out my
responsibilities as police commissioner
unaffected by public opinions demanding
one an outcome over another I examine
the totality of the circumstances and
relied on the facts and I stand before
you today confident that I have reached
the correct decision and that has
certainly not made it an easy decision I
served for nearly nearly 34 years as a
new york city cop before becoming police
commissioner I can tell you that I had I
been in officers pen at the officers
Pantaleo situation I may have made
similar mistakes and had I made those
mistakes I would have wished I had used
the arrival of backup officers to give
the situation more time to make that
arrest I'd run if wish that I had
released my crib before it became a
chokehold every time I watch that video
I say to myself as probably all of you
do to mr. garner don't do it comply the
officer Pantaleo
don't do it I said that about the
decisions made by both officer Pantaleo
and mr. Connor but none of us can take
back our decisions most especially when
they lead to the death of another human
being I was not in officer Pantaleo
situation that day I was chief of patrol
and later that year chief of Department
in that position I proposed our
neighborhood policing model so that the
same cops would be in the same
neighborhoods every day so that
relationships would replace
preconceptions so that problem-solving
and prevention would become tools
officers were trained in and supported
and using and therefore one of the
greatest the great challenges of the
police confession here in New York City
and elsewhere will always remain
arresting someone who intends to resist
that arrest communication and
de-escalation techniques are employed
where possible but more often than the
police and the public alike would
perform varying levels of force are used
to ensure compliance society gives our
police the legal authority to use
acceptable levels of force when
necessary because police cannot
otherwise do their job every day in New
York people receive summonses are
arrested by officers of that any
physical force being used but some
people choose to verbally and/or
physically resist the enforcement action
lawfully being taken against them those
situations are unpredictable and
dangerous to everyone involved the
street is never the right place to argue
the appropriateness of an arrest that is
what our courts are for being a police
officer it's one of the hardest jobs in
the world this is bad is not a statement
to elicit sympathy from those we serve
it's a fact cops have to make choices
sometimes very quickly every single day
some are split-second life-and-death
choices often times they are choices
that will be thoroughly and repeatedly
examined by those with much more time to
think about them than the police officer
had and those decisions are scrutinized
and second-guessed both fairly and
unfairly
the one believes that officer Pantaleo
got out of bed on July 17 2014
thinking he would make choices and take
actions during an otherwise routine
arrest that would lead to another
person's death but an officer's choices
and actions even made under extreme
pressure matter is unlikely that mr.
garner thought he was in such poor
health that a brief struggle with the
police would cause his death he should
have decided against resisting arrest
but a mammoth family lost his life and
that is an irreversible tragedy and a
hard-working police officer with the
family a man who took this job to do
good to make a difference in his home
community has now lost his chosen career
and that is a different kind of tragedy
in this case the unintended consequence
of mr. Garner's death must have a
consequence of its own therefore I agree
with the Deputy Commissioner of trials
legal findings and recommendations
there's clear that Daniel Pantaleo can
no longer effectively serve as a New
York City police officer and carrying
out the courts virtus verdict in this
case I take no pleasure I know that many
will disagree with this decision and
that is their right there are absolutely
no victors here today not the garner
family not the community at large and
certainly not the courageous men and
women of the police department who put
their own lives on the line every single
day in service and to the people of this
great city today is a day of reckoning
but can also be a day of reconciliation
you must vote we must move forward
together as one city determined to
secure safety for all safety for all New
Yorkers and safety for every police
officer working daily to protect all of
us on they'll take your questions
which position
to go have you postpone this decision as
you said was very difficult I'm not
going to talk about rumors that this is
let's talk about the decision that
Rosemarie made the decision that was
affirmed by Deputy Commissioner Tucker
and the decision I just made you today
it's an extremely difficult decision hey
Mark I think you know me long enough by
now that this was not an easy decision
it's not something that I could make
over a few hours and I've been taking
I've been thinking about this since the
day I was sworn in that Police
Commissioner so it's uh the decision was
made in the last last couple of days
Tony
that he's being terminated so whatever
contributions he made to the pension
system he'll get back Marsha Marsha hold
on
so immediately I'm sending out my
remarks and the video of this press
conference so they know what you all
know and I've been a cop a long time and
if I was still a cop I'd probably be mad
at me I would you know looking out for
us but I am it's my responsibility as
police commissioner to look out for the
city and certainly to look out for the
New York City police officers they took
this job to make a difference and you
all know the city's been transformed
I've had a lot of help but it's the cops
out there right now and the thousands
that have come before us that continue
to make this city safe some will be
angry and I have a great executive staff
these police officers do a terrific job
each and every day and we'll have to
work through this it's a resilient
organization
I did this based on the evidence and
testimony at the trial now that's that's
not this is my decision
there there are a couple possible
outcomes but this is the decision that
the police commissioner makes I mean
that this is a disciplinary case like
other disciplinary cases and it's my
decision I'm gonna get to you in a
second hold on Rocco I did not follow
the trial day to day I waited for the
testimony to come up and the evidence to
come up I have a staff that works me up
in my office they do disciplinary cases
they reviewed it
we got the Rose Marie's decision we
looked at that and we moved forward
right here the blonde hair I have not
commissioner Tucker has attempted to
reach out to them a couple of different
phone calls didn't happen too long ago
waiting for a callback I'll wait in the
corner over there
now this is this is the first time this
is the announcement was from here what's
that I talked to I talked with mayor de
Blasio about process and possible
outcomes Ashley
so this all this whole situation
transpired in seconds I'm sure no one in
this room if they were involved in no
one in this room probably had to accept
the police had to arrest anybody and a
physical struggle and if they could
recount step for step what they did I
think that would be nothing short of a
miracle this is the decision rosemary
made Rosemarie made this is was affirmed
by the first deputy commissioner
agreeing with that yes this is there's a
department trial there's a process
rosemarie made the decision again
affirmed by Ben Tucker and I agree with
both of their findings
so immediately after this back in 2014
Ben Tucker was the Deputy Commissioner
training still at the time we put all of
our police officers through a three day
course including de-escalation we've
done a lot of other things that we've
done fair and impartial policing and
every police officer has wearing a body
one camera now there's a lot of things
that came out of this incident and every
time there's an incident that affects
the NYPD there's always something to
learn right behind you yeah
without
yep
we're losing
his officer Pantaleo had 289 arrests as
far as we can tell searching for all the
record no one no other person that he
arrested was injured yeah did have a
number of resisting arrest which is not
unusual he had some C or CC Arby's the
one that was that where he was that were
substantiated that was a bad stop not
use of force so all this has to be taken
its totality out of that 289 arrests
there were a number of gun arrests and
what does the NYPD do each and every day
we try to reduce gun violence and in in
this city so that I have to look at have
to look at his record that's part of the
disciplinary system so I'm not gonna
stand up here and say I didn't think
about that but I had to be guided by the
facts that were brought out in the
department trial and that was sent up to
our office if I see a lot of journalists
here that went through 2014 the protest
the murder of Glen J and liu and rafael
ramos to say that you know that's always
that's Adam that's never out of my mind
I think about that every day whether
there's a department trial or not so I
can't stand up in here and say I didn't
I didn't think about that but that's not
what how I made my final decision I'm
gonna be right here
this is the outcome of our trial we had
needed it to be fair at fair and
impartial and it was a fair and
impartial trial right here with the
glasses that there's we from day one we
said that there was going to be a fair
and impartial trial and this is this is
the result make no mistake about it this
is a tragedy for the garner family I
fully understand that mr. garner was
somebody's son somebody's dad everybody
in the NYPD understands that it's an
immediate termination
I agreed with the the content of her
decision on who didn't go yet right here
yeah
tralala came out that a lot of the
partner
- arrest did any part of the other
people accepted by company USA
right after this job Resnick's people
from internal affairs looked at each
officer that was involved in this there
was a number of civilian witnesses a
number of police officer witnesses and
it was sergeant adonis to receive
charges and officer Pantaleo parent
so I can't remove myself from the fact
that I was a uniform cop for 34 years
but I think that's what makes this so
difficult that every member of law
enforcement in this country that works
and keeps this country safe and the city
safe looked at that and said that could
possibly be me and that's it's in my DNA
it's it's Who I am
it's but as police commissioner I have
to think about the city and I have to
think about the rules and regs of the
NYPD and make sure that people follow in
the back
said
I think I stated that I said if I was
still a police officer I would probably
not be happy but we've been through a
lot of things in the NYPD and it's great
history I know that men and women that
do this job are resilient
somebody calls for help thousand nine
one one somebody Flags them down they're
not going to think about this decision
they're going to think about why they
took this job and they're going to help
that person no matter who they are
there's something in particular was
there a moment when you realize that and
what do you see his Commissioner that
the officer on the street so well as I
said I went through the testimony looked
at the video a number of times I know
what the definition of a chokehold is
this is what led me to this decision and
again a difficult decision in the back
you can under civil service law I can
use I think it's article 78 look at the
DC LLM to give you a further explanation
of what that process is after the press
conference
would have kept his pension as well and
how close were you to embracing that
there were a number of different
outcomes you can see based on the
charges you could have been found not
guilty of both he was found guilty of
one could have been given a vested
interest or he could have been
terminated it's something that I had to
consider but that wasn't part of my
final decision yep right here
kind of probably not no yep
it's there's a final decision can't be
overturned that one second let's see
Marsha back to you
I can't speculate on that Rocco you had
a question you know right this is this
is a big day in the police department
and I'm sure most if not all are paying
attention to this as I said we take this
job to do good and I'm sure I'm sure
that the police officers that raise
their right hand and sworn oath will
continue to do their jobs
testimony the recollection proceedings
and the opinion that he didn't in fact
lie but there was a swirl of combat
as they stated before I'm affirming
judge Maldonado's decision funny
why wouldn't you let
so this no one's asked me this yet so
I'll just throw it out here what
whatever we learned from this case what
I learned is that we wouldn't let this
linger for five years it's too long it's
unfair to the family it's unfair to
everybody involved in this case well it
depends on what the situation is now we
would probably have more forceful
discussions with the other agencies that
are investigating this to make sure that
we can proceed with our administrative
charges I think we have over here yep
mark
now after I have to do what's first I
have to look at Rose Marie's decision I
have to look at Ben's affirmation and be
guided by that now there was this
pressure from on any number of sides
here to know make this decision make
that decision I had to do in the end
what I felt was the correct decision
nobody else
part of Justices investigation taking
Salonika do you regret deferring to them
for so long until last year regret is
probably too strong a word but I
definitely makes me rethink going
forward how would we proceed with
administrative trials
yeah we're in the process of finalizing
that yeah it's gonna be it'll it'll be
soon it'll be this year it's a
disciplinary case we have to make sure
that we look all the facts have to make
sure we have a conducted thorough
investigation and then we move forward
said it again Marcia yeah we did
immediately followed we did
de-escalation training right here and
then you have one okay and then that's
it yep
with our family we feel about all this
you put the pressure in the police
department what do you want the
residents of New York City to take from
this so what I want the residents of New
York City